bueno pues el juicio ha empezado y tras
una pausa se acaba de reanudar hace
pocos minutos existe la esposa de nava
una carta detenida brevemente durante
las protestas del pasado domingo en
estos momentos el argumento de la
acusación es precisamente ese demostrar
que naval de incumplió los términos de
esa especie de libertad condicional que
estaba disfrutando y no se presentó a
los controles periódicos así lo ha
relatado un funcionario de prisiones a
lo que el propio naval ni ha contestado
no podía documentar el lugar en el que
me encontraba porque yo mismo estaba en
coma no obstante la defensa de naval
ha insistido en que aunque nada al himno
contestó a las autoridades
penitenciarias sí que estuvo en contacto
en todo momento el abogado de naval y
que ahora mismo él está defendiendo en
este juicio para evitar que el opositor
vuelva a prisión a cumplir una pena que
podría estar en torno a tres años porque
habría que descontarle diez meses de
arresto domiciliario que cumplió en el
pasado